sure you're aware of the Francis ingano
news sign with the pfl have you seen the
terms on that deal and stuff like that I
saw some of it I still have a hard time
believing that he was going to make as
much money as he would in the UFC as the
UFC champion with pay-per-view stuff you
know but for some people a very rare
sector of people it's less about the
money and more about the impact and I
think that's kind of where francis's
heart is I mean I think yeah I wish him
well I I saw him in Vegas actually I ran
him to it at a steakhouse hey man what's
happening what are you doing you know
what's what's next we were talking about
boxing we were talking about whatever
and it uh you know worked out well for
him so